i want to start with how excited i am to
see all eight episodes of this series um
and i'm i'm curious what are you most
excited for people to see on the show
well i personally am very excited to see
uh for people to see the
these all these beings um
coming together not despite of their
differences but because of their
differences
and being able to to enhance and add to
each other and uh
together journey through many many
different uh difficult obstacles i love
that i love what you just said i think
for me it's similar it's um
our differences are our strength and i
think that we are empowered by our
differences and i think that's sort of
an underlying message of the show is
there anything that you think would
surprise fans of lord of the rings to
like learn about the making of the rings
of power i think so there were like 90
people in the costume department alone
so i feel like um
it took
just
a nation of people yeah we were like a
small town essentially yeah like like
2500 crew or something like that and
there was i mean there was so so many
elements um
and sometimes when you see the the the
little
the moss or the
forgot the name like those little green
patches that grow on trees um that that
you know
things like even things like that were
created you know even things like that
were painted you had dedicated artists
creating every little corner of of this
world
um so i think i think the bts is going
to be
[Music]
scrumptious for those who like that kind
of stuff which i do
without spoilers which episode of the
eight is your favorite and why
six
i'd say i'd say six i think it's a
toss-up for me between six and
the third episode of the six episode for
me it's between two and six but that's
probably just for personal storyline
reasons a lot of people have told me
episode seven so i'm i obviously must
know that seven is a huge episode based
on how many people said it interesting
well good on them
[Laughter]
from the original uh lord of the rings
movies do you have a favorite moment i
think i mean i think for me i still i
and i think for many people you still
feel this burst of joy when you see uh
photo running to me candle you know and
the music comes in
of course the tale continues and it
becomes more and more deep and more and
more dramatic but that you know when you
when you cozy up to watch it uh i think
that tells you it puts you right right
into the world
yep i agree
you know the lord of the rings and
tolkien's words have uh have resonated
with generations people have loved his
mater the world and lord of the rings
for for so long what do you think it is
about the lord of the rings and his
storytelling that has resonated with so
many people i know that he he said
talking has said that he you know
doesn't believe in allegory but
there is so much in his writing and his
his storytelling that resonates
with what's happening in the world today
uh people can find themselves in these
characters and the characters in our
show
there's everyone's gonna find someone
some being that they
can relate to and i think that's the
beauty of tolkien's world that he
created is
it's so relevant even today it's
relevant yeah i think no matter how
fantastical big small
superpower
high of
human um
they're all rooted in a truth and a
personal truth that any anybody can uh
tether to and feel related to and see
themselves in these in these beings i
think uh that's what makes tolkien so
effective on that donation to stop i'm
just going to say i really can't wait to
watch
all the episodes uh thank you so much
for your time
you